vous avez un esprit extrêmement critique
attention ça va fusée
réunis enfin réuni alors vous êtes pas
retrouvé pour rien puisque tous les
soirs à 20h40 sur M6 4 millions et demi
de téléspectateurs suivent caméra 800
000 de plus qu'à la rentrée c'est énorme
c'est vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup là d'un coup la première fois
que ça nous arrive
on est surtout très surpris alors c'est
une idée à vous ils vend un soir sur le
chemin entre la gare et chez vous vous
avez cette idée ça vous est venu comment
ça nous est venu parce qu'on cherchait
déjà depuis longtemps un petit format
moyen
de faire de faire de jouer la comédie
quoi parce qu'on était parti sur une
voie où il fallait rentrer à la
télévision par n'importe quel moyen ça a
été tu vas être long mais je me lance
dans le narratif c'est normal c'est
toute une carrière donc après on a
recentré on était entré par la porte des
magazines des divertissements puis après
on voulait faire de la comédie quoi donc
on cherchait un format économique pour
pouvoir rentrer à nouveau à la
télévision vous avez trouvé cette idée
qui est de raconter une entreprise à
travers ce que voit et entend une une
machine à café c'est un lieu clé de la
machine à café bah oui c'est un endroit
fédérateur parce qu'il y a pas une
entreprise enfin dans les PME notamment
et tout en France en Europe dans le
monde sans aucun doute où il est pas une
machine à café c'est un endroit où
effectivement les gens se retrouvent
pour parler d'une autre manière parler
de leur vie en superficie certes voilà
de parler d'eux-mêmes aussi et puis de
refaire le monde donc c'était un vivier
pour la comédie formidable tout se passe
là en fait
tout se fait se défait devant la machine
à café
alors les personnages vous Bruno vous
êtes responsables des achats
syndical crapule un syndicaliste
théoriquement extrêmement engagé et
courageux et dans la dans les faits très
vœux très obséquieux avec les grands
avaler un valet une ordure et vous êtes
cadre commercial un peu frimeur c'est ça
non j'ai pas les moyens d'être friand
déjà je suis disons que j'ai mis 15 ans
avant d'arriver à à la force du poignet
je suis plutôt un gros vendeur voilà
alors il y a plein de personnages et
puis il y a des guest stars il y a eu
Elie Semoun Jamel José Garcia
et puis alors il y a plein de
personnages et puis il y a aussi des des
stars il y a eu ces Moon José Garcia qui
d'autre et Jamel non je crois non jamais
non jamais il est jamais venu
bon ben on va regarder à quoi ça
ressemble c'est comment on fait quand
même attention
ça c'est le DVD puis il faut recommencer
pour la cassette
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien écrit ouais c'est bien écrit
on a une trentaine d'auteurs qui
travaillent avec nous c'est vrai c'est
vrai
avec nous il y a un noyau dur beaucoup
de 15h beaucoup de filles notamment les
comédiennes Armel qui jouent Maëva qui
écrit beaucoup de sketchs qui était
costumière au départ oui tout à fait
comment tu sais ça
me suffit comme explication alors le
tournage donc c'est une semaine sur deux
l'autre semaine c'est l'écriture des
scénaris et Bruno vous avez été obligé
Bruno
de quitter la Belgique et de revenir
habiter en France
elle dit quoi Frédéric si Frédéric ben
elle était séance vous voyez plus quoi
en fait on était tous séparés parce que
moi je passais beaucoup de temps ici
avec
Yvan alors elle commence à avoir des
doutes ça devenait ingérable cette
histoire donc maintenant j'ai ramené ma
femme à côté de mon voisin mais ça
risque pas de [__] votre couple en
l'air ça fait le couple avec Frédéric
divorce bien entendu c'est elle qui
préférait rentrer aussi parce qu'elle
travaille beaucoup plus en France
qu'elle ne travaille en Belgique
donc vous êtes extrêmement sollicité
tous les deux par les filles on peut le
dire devant M6 tous les jours on vient
de parler de nos femmes si ils regardent
donc jamais
attendez vous avez un esprit extrêmement
critique
attention ça va fusée dès que vous voyez
les gonzesse vous savez tout de suite
tout de suite trouver les tuiles amour
vous savez pourquoi je vous dis ça parce
que vous allez faire une interview tue
l'amour tu es là
ça commence par vous oh [__]
l'attention là ça va être chaud le
détail tu l’amour chez une fille c'est
les cheveux gras les mains moites les
poils sous les bras ou le duvet sous le
nez
je sais pas moi un talon cassé ça ça
fait beaucoup en fin de soirée sur un
parking de boîte à Melun
[Applaudissements]
justement
justement le super tue l'amour c'est les
mauvaises odeurs la mauvaise haleine ou
le mauvais goût
évidemment le mauvais goût qui serait
d'avoir mauvaise haleine
le tue l'amour à la plage c'est une
fille qui garde le haut une fille qui se
fout à poil direct ou une fille
maléfique qui garde le haut c'est vrai
que c'est quand même assez bizarre quoi
en même temps
mais suffisamment ça touche pour la
montrer
parce que vous pensez que quand elle
garde le haut elle a enlevé le bac quand
même ah bah oui j'ai regardé
alors le tue l'amour en boîte une fille
qui danse désynchronisée
une fille qui dégouline dessus
une fille
ça peut être la seule occasion c'est
vrai que ça peut aider ça peut aider
donc ça tue peut-être son amour mais
peut-être pas le vôtre en tout cas le
baiser qui tue l'amour c'est une fille
qui embrasse tout le monde la pleine
bouche
une fille qui embrasse son chien sur le
museau
ou une fille qui fait 4 bises parce que
chez nous c'est quatre
[Rires]
pas nécessairement confiance
on se dit ouh là ça doit être une fille
légère et c'est un euphémisme alors le
tue l'amour avant de conclure
je prends pas la pilule
je te préviens je suis frigide
et tu sais j'ai mes qu'est-ce que c'est
le deuxième déjà
un gros qui frappe derrière la porte en
disant je suis bûcheron ça fait une
semaine que j'attendais à la porte
et c'est son mari alors le tue l'amour
au lit
c'est la fille qui bouge pas la fille
qui hurle ou la fille qui pleure
fille qui pleure ça veut dire que tu as
pas tu as loupé le challenge je suis
frigide d'accord et si elle pleure de
rire c'est plus encore bon maintenant on
se réveille tu l'amour au réveil la
fille la fille qui fait un gargarisme en
se lavant les dents
la fille qui m'a un déodorant sans
prendre de douche
qui ne l'a fait ou la fermer qui se
trahit ou la fille qui laisse la porte
des toilettes ouverte quand elle y va
alors ça ça peut être un jeu ça peut
être un truc érotique
pas le matin
je sais pas moi [__] tu m'aides pas
toi aussi hein
sans prendre de douche voilà pourquoi
parce que ça veut dire merde et tout
elle fait comme moi et tout c'est pas
cool
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu